[Applause]
Earthling
of people you people
it's Friday and you know what that means
we give everyone in the audience kill
Mead's credit card number
all right now let's welcome tonight's
guests
he secretly hates being the second
sexiest guy at Fox co-host of fox and
friends we get Pete Texas
her self-defense against the left is
common sense communications director had
never back down pat Aaron perini
yeah
she's like cottage cheese white low in
fat and popular at Rest Homes Fox News
contributor captive
and air traffic over JFK is constantly
telling him to duck my massive sidekick
in the NWA World Heavyweight Champion
Paris
all right
we have started but before we get to
some new stories it's Friday so let's do
this
Greg's leftovers
I don't know man I'm wearing a
turtleneck and it's almost the summer
maybe maybe I'm hiding something
that's when you wear turtlenecks maybe
you're a poet ah there you go I'm not
saying the second part
all right leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading them
so if they suck we'll tar and feather a
writer right after the show
and then we'll push him into the water
and watch him drown
here we go please be good this week
President Biden welcomed Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi to the White
House
quote it's the least I can do said Joe
after we stole all their land
[Applause]
on Tuesday the president hosted a forum
about artificial intelligence with tech
leaders in SF when asked what the most
positive part of the trip was he said I
guess being in a city where nobody
yelled at me for taking a dump on the
sidewalk
all right
it's funny because it's true
sausage maker Johnsonville is recalling
more than 42 000 pounds on pork sausage
for possible contamination with plastic
fibers
fortunately authorities were able to
track all 42 000 pounds to a single
location in New York City
you people disgusting a Florida woman
wearing only a towel and drinking a Four
Loco stop me there
was arrested for allegedly letting kids
photograph her naked in a Dollar General
parking lot
she's since been promoted to head of
Florida tourism
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
premiered in La this week I don't want
to give away the plot but the ancient
Relic he's looking for this time is
horrifying
good news for the Oakland A's Nevada
just approved 380 million dollars to
build a new stadium in Las Vegas it will
be just like the regular Stadium except
fans will be able to buy hookers
foreign
which is great the section of I-95 in
Philly that collapsed will reopen within
two weeks which means Pennsylvania can
now Focus their efforts on rebuilding
another total disaster
it was revealed recently that the U.S
ranked 60th in the world in penis size
it would have been even higher but the
average was thrown off by a single
participant
[Applause]
I think higher means lower or desire
mean upper or lower mean bad no matter
how you swing it they got you yeah
a British family was stunned after its
pet tortoise was found miles from home
after missing for two years when asked
for an explanation the tortoise said I
have no idea it all happened so fast
an LAPD drug dog is being hailed as a
hero after sniffing out 15 pounds of
heroin a kilogram of Fentanyl and an
assault rifle that were inside a vending
machine
so one thing we can all agree on that's
one hell of a vending machine
we need one of those according to an IRS
whistleblower Hunter Biden made him
proper tax deductions on tens of
thousands of dollars he spent on hookers
and a sex club
wait he may not supposed to pay taxes on
that stuff
[Applause]
you asked for sex clubs I keep mine in
the glove compartment
yes
the same four Transit cops nabbed and
accused murderer and suspected serial
Slasher in NYC in a 24-hour period
the kids are defunding the police
responded saying see we only need four
cops
that was cute
what's wrong with you people nope I
don't want your sympathy Clapper
I'm not uh whatever that other show is
okay finally math and reading scores for
13 year olds in the U.S have hit the
lowest levels in decades but don't worry
those kids have no idea what that even
means
all right
clap for the illiterate children clap
for the kids now to some news the
feral Monsters of the view say they've
never heard of you know who through the
show that makes mornings hell claim that
my name doesn't ring a bell it's time
for
our view on The View
ugh
yeah the witch is coven finally shows me
some loving yesterday on The View yours
truly was the subject of conversation
apparently the broads have no idea who I
am or so they say hit it Gladys
said that Gutfeld talks about you all
the time who is he
[Applause]
I guess he's just obsessed with me
next Joy is going to say she's never
heard of carbs
seriously her denial of knowing me is as
believable as a red hair
but Obsession I mean come on Joy where
would you even get that idea
like Joy behar's face it's looking worse
and worse by the day or full of crap
than Joy Behar after a night is scotch
and Taco Bell her being named Joy is
like me being named ugly Joy wasn't
there on the show apparently Mondays are
her days off when she feeds in the
pasture it now smells like a humid day
inside Joy behar's MooMoo the motives
stink worse than Joy behar's jog bra
I mean assuming she jogs oh wait there
she is
[Music]
she has a point maybe I am obsessed but
some people are obsessed with Bigfoot
and they don't get to see him on TV
every afternoon and if they did could
they tell the two apart I don't know
but yeah it's true I am obsessed with
her the way a mongoose is obsessed with
snakes
but I'm obsessed with a lot of things
he sucks harder than Brian stelter on a
duck fat Slurpee they've thrown more
shade his way that stelter does sitting
on a snow globe or stelter who's built
like an unripe avocado I haven't seen
that violent a reaction since Brian
stelter was shorter to McNugget in his
Happy Meal they're racing to the bottom
faster than Brian stelter eating a can
of concentrated tomato paste she's
alleged to be more careless with guns
than stelter is with carbs
and what about this fan favorite
this is Kayla lemieu here she is along
with her friends Brian and stelter I
wonder if Airlines make her check those
things those boobs could be their own
country if the school board still stands
behind the teacher no other choice in
the unlikely event of a water emergency
landing your shop teacher can be used as
a flotation device if they were States
they'd be worth 98 electoral votes this
story is getting bigger and bouncier
boobs are so big you'll need a sherpa to
climb them when students saw those
Shadows that meant six more weeks of
nipples the size of doorknob
so my point is
he accessed with a lot of things that
make me laugh every single day of my
life and you little lady are right up
there with them I'd love to have you on
our show sometime we'll even stock The
Green Room with your favorite frozen
mice
that's what you feed them
so uh cat were you uh pretty surprised
that they didn't know what this show was
uh no I'm also not surprised that
there's one part of the video from the
show yesterday that you left out oh
really yeah can we roll that please
I don't want to show that much but I've
seen it who is that Greg gutfeld's one
of the hosts of the five who
if I don't have anything nice to say I
generally don't say anything at all I
would just say this the show should be
called cat tymph not Gutfeld because
she's the funny one on it
somebody
somebody's flirting with little cat over
here well she's the Republican one at
the table but I just think as a
Libertarian I'm always looking to find
common ground with other people because
nobody really shares my politics so I
find some common ground in the view
where she thinks I'm funny and I agree
there you go Tyrus do you think it's a
good strategy on on the behalf of the
view to pretend we don't exist when we
know they know we exist that's a
brilliant idea I do it all the time yeah
Gutfeld I'm sorry not ringing the bell
usually at the airport yeah all the time
yeah huh really I sit next to him really
no this is what elitists do who can't
like if you don't know who someone is
how did you know to automatically hate
him
like I mean that's the cult that's how
fake she is gut field never heard of him
don't like him why because because why
that's why I just turned in one of my
kids because why yeah because I don't
know who he is never heard of him at all
in my entire life but why because I
don't know
because they are the last TV show to
talk about high turnover we've been
rolling three steady for a long time
yeah we don't take breaks in the
commercial to get away from each other
well that's what the drink is for yes
how and oh man uh gee uh Megan McCain
how'd that go yeah Rosie O'Donnell or
any of these previous
fellow employees because one of the
things they said was that no one walks
away from money right so
they got people running away from it
over there so other than the occasional
person who's playing sick home from
school and leaves the TV on they know
who everyone is especially everyone
who's beating them like this is
ridiculous Bill Maher did it too I think
that was the the thing across the board
with this show and his success is if
they don't acknowledge it it doesn't
happen well to coin a phrase acknowledge
us because they knew that cat was funny
how did you figure that out other than
reading her book or going one of her
Live Events or watching her five nights
a week on the Gutfeld show whatever is
easier and they seem cheap to me so I'm
sure they've probably just watched it
you know Aaron you're a woman
yeah nailed that yeah yeah so uh would
you know any women who watch
The View because I you know most of my
friends are women but uh none of them
watch The View I don't know a lot of
people who watch The View and actually I
worked on the hill at the same time as
Alyssa so I've known Alyssa for years
but this speaks to the larger issue with
the view right Barbara Walters started
the program to like have descending
views and you would get into fights and
you couldn't get up from the table she
wanted Fierce dialogue and now they're
saying that they don't know your show
one of the most popular if not the most
popular show in late night how does that
speak to the view they don't they're
looking for descent they aren't looking
for other opinion or opportunity they
want one and if they don't agree with
your view they shout you down and boo
you off the show they do it to any
Republican candidate who goes on that
show they regularly interrupt and boom
and that's why people my age don't watch
that show very often or at all I don't
think I've ever watched it except for
when a candidate is on it yeah I've only
watched it you know I okay I watch it
every morning
repeat the acting was terrible in that
segment it was like Brian Austin Green
when Megan Fox dumped him and he was
like ah no big deal he was
self-mutilating in a camper oh it was
acting yeah there's no doubt what's more
likely that Joy Behar doesn't know who
Greg Gutfeld is or that Joy beher spends
her nights with a bucket full of chicken
wings prying herself to sleep scrolling
videos of you making fun of her
yeah
which one's more likely
probably the latter probably the last
second hand that she's she knows who I
am because people tell her the insults
oh no doubt tell her the end Greg said
this the other day to be like
that's boy
no no Whoopi's the one who doesn't like
the Jews which one doesn't like the Jews
I get confused I'm not I'm not taking
that baby all right
it's not like dude
apologizing for something about Jews
then they have to apologize to something
about Christians so they offend
everybody they're always offending
somebody but it did Tyrus is right this
is their strategy yeah like 100 Biden we
don't know him we don't know about his
laptop yeah everything's fine there they
denied as long as they can I'm cool so I
know nothing yes yes hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else